you know it's it's so odd because that
was
about exactly a year ago uh
right now and and you know the the world
was much more innocent back then and and
now of course
within weeks we got shut down in
shooting uh your honor
and had to come back seven months later
to finish it so
you ended up doing it all in masks and
all of that
yeah um which is which is
terrible i don't know if uh if the other
actors have worked under the protocols
but it's difficult um with the with the
masks and the shields
and you know i'm i'm 65 years old
and i've been to my fair share of rock
concerts and i know i've lost some
hearing
uh and i hear someone i'm working with
an actor and i'm going
some big guns
[Laughter]
i have no idea what they're saying so
did you know that was
challenging i do it when i can't hear
someone
i take my mask off like i hear through
my mouth
when i was i was i was doing a play at
the national uh
a few years ago and it was very
demanding as we know doing theater
and i would shout aloud in the play so i
would designate
one day a week where i wouldn't talk if
it was an off day
and so i would go into a pub for lunch
or something like that and they would
i said
and and i'd write a little note i'm i'm
not talking and so then they
would go okay
you are not talking today
not death
you